The premise of the project
is that economists are too pompous.
One reason we don't get past
the first sentence is that people shut their ears
because they know they've heard these words.
Many of the things economists say are probably
relevant and useful, but we say it in ways
that put off people.
Many miles away in the southwest corner of the city
in a circumscribed neighborhood
Monty ponders under a dry tap.
Sarnath really is an economist,
he's just managed to put a number of layers
around him so that people don't
immediately run away when they see him
The inhabitants of the city of Gates
are linked together by their common dream
that of possessing an extra bedroom.
Abhijit knows, clearly, about greed.
No, he's not greedy
I'm very greedy
But he knows the general... he's
a blackbelt in economics.
With this grant, Abhijit and I am collaborating
to make an insubordinate theatrical lecture
in which Abhijit speaks about certain
guiding principles to understand water
water crisis, water management.
The lectures are about water
but water is a context for the intersection
of any number of forces in economics.
Globalization, greed, rainfall,
climate change, everything hits water.
So water is a wonderful context for
bringing together any number of these
key ideas in economics.
With this series of lectures,
which have humor, imagination
warmth, explanation, and a rich
cast of characters who appear,
as I said, and then reappear
as if it's like a soap opera being told,
but by an economist.
Art is how we construct new languages
so in a sense, that's at the core of what we're
trying to do. We're trying to construct a new language
for saying the same things.
New languages have the function
that they wake us up.
I think that's the... if we get there,
that would be success.
If we woke up people.